i have two consenting adults yeah can
you pedophilia role play i always wonder
this always
yeah you would wonder
oh these white
panties wonder about these panties her
fiance is sweating right now come on
boys hold me down
we've never done that but i recently got
into role play okay and
i've had p i talked about in my stand up
but i've had people ask me if i do the
young thing and i'm i'm questioning
is like school girl role play
wildly interesting what is role playing
like what what what do people get out of
that [ __ ] can you guys explain that's a
very submissive thing to say is this
super power powerful maybe it is i might
be a [ __ ] total sub but like
come on what are we playing like what's
up dude well when you've been in a
relationship for nine years you kind of
have to like
correct invent things and also it's like
make believe it's it's fun you get to
like make a character
i think you guys just love acting like
you're like hollywood people no it's we
don't want to bobby is tired of [ __ ]
kalila he we want to [ __ ] other people
so we become those other people ah
you've been together a decade
[Music]
what is the shoe one oh yeah like i've
been he's been an aristocrat and i've
been a shoemaker
like that's a role play that we do yeah
like i go door-to-door making clogs for
rich aristocrats and he's one of the
aristocrats that i sighed so what do you
say what do you say when you show up
good sir you know stuff like that
and then
and you're not dying laughing during
this whole thing
does bobby have an accent too
he does he's a very rich fat chinese man
in this oh he's not even korean he's
chinese that's his dream yeah he
switches um yeah yeah um but yeah that's
that's one of the things yeah yeah
that's his role play
somebody we couldn't tell the difference
anyways
huge stretch yeah you stretched you just
go over there and just bind his feet
that just seems crazy
well there's another that's what leads
me to my question you have a character
he plays which is called virgin brandon
that really gets me off
age has not been determined but he's
likely very young okay and very very
thankful that you know older susan me
is giving him this chance to
can i tell you something
i if i'm 100 certain if you were a
teacher kids would get [ __ ]
i'm 100 and not in like a i want to take
advantage of them way in like you'd see
like this like sad distraught kid and
you'd be like i can make him feel better
i can heal him and i can take him under
my wing i i know that but i only i have
a kink for for old fatties
i have never been with guys younger than
me i like them old and fat why
i don't know i feel safe bad thing
but maybe sometimes there's security
there it's like oh this guy's not gonna
leave me yeah
possibly
i was just gonna say that he's almost
left me several times so that doesn't
matter
why why
no i'm just crazy maybe he did
why what happened what was the beef no
like i just mean that i am usually the
problem in the relationship and so like
if it were to end it would be him
leaving me i think and what do you do to
cause these problems ah you know we
started dating when i was in my early
20s so i was just like a crazy person
and
you know demanded moving in together and
you know i was an ultimatum girl and i
don't think guys like that oh wow yeah
are you are you an ultimatum girl yeah
you gotta try roleplay i think you would
like it yeah what should i role play
this fun i mean i have a feeling like a
heterosexual male 1 yeah
you could replace a dom that could be
fun dumb um you could roleplay as a
repairman and a homeowner
so you're a repairman maybe your your
wife could be a homeowner okay how would
you afford the
okay well i i guess it doesn't work if
you okay yeah it's like an analogy oh no
it's yeah it's a fantasy thing you can
do cheerleader and football player that
could be fun okay you could be a
cheerleader okay
honestly i can't i can't do it i bet you
could i swear i cuz i was like
[ __ ] crying laughing i thought it was
really funny and sometimes i do get a
little nervous and giggle but like
it's still hot and you still keep going
with it i have a character called
neighborhood girl
and um she's just a girl in the
neighborhood who comes by the house she
maybe she wants to [ __ ] you she might
want to rob you it's kind of a thrill
that's that's the role i play do you rob
them do you rob them sometimes no i've
never robbed him um well not in the role
play but um
do you
is there something like that's maybe an
extension of you that's just like a
little different version of you that you
would feel the chef in the server extra
sexy
no
what if she was something extra sex what
if you were you she can't get sexier oh
but what if you guys are both scottish i
will then that could be good that would
be really hot no no what i will say is
like um
like if we're being if we're being
serious
if we're being serious
you're deflected so hard
yeah no imagine you guys are both
scottish you're a highlander okay she's
just a nurse trying to heal you after
you got your arm cut off in the battle
of colada
yes now we're doing it we're all playing
yeah
italian comes in
i'm taking notes no no i
what i will say is like i know maybe
this is like an extension of
drunk sex so it's like reducing
inhibitions and maybe through the
character you have no inhibitions
because this is what the character's
saying so you get to kind of access a
part of yourself that's actually more
real you absolutely nailed it right
that's yes right so it's like you really
want to be these things exist within you
and the character is just the
comfortable way to be the neighborhood
girl you really just want to go in there
and just start taking [ __ ] or like
seduce him or be [ __ ] up and then any
time that like cringe moment or the
embarrassing thing happens you get to go
no this is just the character totally so
it's like a safe version of that i just
use uh alcohol
for that that works two problems i've
never tried that either so i don't know
but yeah but what i would say is that
now i understand it why people want to
do that sometimes we want to just get
out of our heads
and that's what the character thing is
stone cold sober you guys will go well
obviously you're sober right i rarely
drink yeah yeah so okay yeah yeah yeah
you gotta try it i mean do you do do you
do role playing stuff yes no you don't i
pretend to be bobby lee yeah that is
true i like that and then how do you how
do you do it for you i lay on my back
yeah and milo comes over exactly
and then my wife will do kalyala and
then she'll uh she'll dominate me wow
wow that's true that's how we do it al
do you have a role play that like you're
sleeping with black women
no no have you ever done the role play
cause you're pretty uh yeah just
adventurous sexually like cuffs and
swings and things like that not really
role play yeah unless you role play as a
cop jungle gym
yeah i mean we play
it's a swing you know but yeah no role
play stuff i'm very intimidated by
contraptions oh it's funny just like sex
toys
yeah
i just think that if i go in that
direction i'll always rely on that
that's how i felt about um
uh finger in the butt
explain
what i didn't want to know that i liked
it but did you do it i didn't do it
won't do it you know what i've never
been well
you know me i've never i've had it
licked yeah and then when the girl tried
to go in yeah i was like she tried and
was supposed to answer yeah what's the
answer is a gladiator soup fire thumbs
up
i'm not gonna put the thumbs anywhere
okay but i would love for you to just
surrender because i've never been with a
guy who is who doesn't like it
no i believe that it is to be enjoyed
yes i don't want to rely on that because
i've never taken off my underwear and
there hasn't been [ __ ]
so i know what my wife is putting her
fingers into
so
and it's not like i don't wipe
thoroughly like i actually do put in a
good effort like i really try and it's
every single time you could do some like
prep work what do you mean by that you
know
go on the show
good day
really just make sure everything what he
needs a bidet yeah
you're so rich and you don't have a
bidet i don't believe in it
you like man
yeah he doesn't want to feel it he
doesn't want to know he likes the bidet
yeah yeah dude i spent 45 minutes
scrolling on a bidet once
water squirting yeah 45 minutes he was
floating in the air like a car what is
that
that's me on top take that esther
it's like for the planet you don't want
to waste all the resources that's what
it is yeah yeah i want to get stuff done
i would do one podcast a week and fight
a bidet and i'd sit on their reverse
cowgirl
[Laughter]
you also believe that g-spot's a myth
too yeah the male g-spot male g-spot i
don't believe it really um yeah i have
been unsuccessful in that arena as well
really i've tried to go
in and done everything hit the prostate
and it has not yeah it's [ __ ] it has
not been fruitful wow and when you come
it's not even come that comes out but
then i just blame myself it's just the
fluid
there's no actual sperm in it
this is a myth gay dudes invented so
that they could the gay lobby yeah it's
the gay lobby